one for dinner tonight the gang tacos
spaghetti tacos huh why do you want that
yeah yeah I guess we're making spaghetti
tacos tonight I consider myself a gentle
parent and if you don't know what a
gentle parent is let me school you a
little bit the three key points of
gentle parenting are understanding
empathy and respect letting your child
kind of have autonomy over themselves
and their lives while still being a
parent but something that I've seen
circulating in my little mom groups on
Facebook is that gentle parents
shouldn't say no I don't practice that
because I think kids are gonna here know
in their lives and so shielding them
from that is silly so I wanted to try
something for a week I wanted to try
saying yes to my kids for a week so I
did it and I learned a lot so first I
had to set some ground rules because if
not my house would probably have burned
down first I did not let my kids know
that I was doing this because if they
had known that would have just been pure
chaos so they had no idea that this was
happening second there were some things
that needed to still happen there are
certain hygiene oriented things that
need to happen health oriented things
like you can't have cookies for every
meal but beyond that I let things go and
I said yes and we had some interesting
results it is Saturday morning it is
6:45 in the morning both of my kids are
awake usually I'd have them watch a
little TV so I could get a little extra
sleep but they both are hungry
apparently starving to death and they
want to go to breakfast so I'm gonna get
up and they're gonna go so we're going
to get Jackson's haircut or walking
he wanted to ride his scooter for sure
something I would say no to because I
know my kids I know that we'll get there
get his hair cut and then all end up
lugging the scooter and his younger
brother all the way home but I said yes
we got there fine and lo and behold he
rode his scooter the whole way back -
and that was a pleasant surprise and
that was kind of my first realization of
like well this might not be a bad thing
so they both wanted chicken nuggets for
dinner and they asked if we could sit
and watch Adventure Time while we have
dinner so the one thing that I was most
nervous about in this whole experiment
of saying yes was the food situation if
you are a busy parent like me you know
what it's like getting meals on the
table it's really tough so I have this
rotation of standard meals that I know
work and so I don't deviate from it
because you got something good you just
so when I started saying yes to them the
orders got a little weird so I have some
spaghetti I'm gonna attempt to put it in
a hard taco shell because I feel like a
soft one what's top spaghetti it's gonna
be like pretty weird do you like it yeah
Jackson are you happy yeah Wyatt are you
happy yeah so I think this was the one
thing that my kids cut onto during the
week that I was being a little more
flexible with what I learned from this
whole week of them choosing their foods
is that they're more likely to eat the
entire plate if they've chosen what
they're gonna have this kids on his
third one oh my gosh look at you go
Jackson and ultimately they'll get what
they need nutrition wise just maybe in a
really weird way so this week wasn't all
rainbows and butterflies there were
definitely some slip-ups and some things
that I learned that I definitely should
continue to say no to the kids really
wanted to Starbucks for breakfast so I
said yes and we have a lot of errands to
run today so I wanted to just drive
there
and drive straight from there to go do
our stuff for the day but Jackson really
really wanted to walk because he says he
wants to get exercise it's about 85
degrees out right now and Wyatt is
insisting on being held so we're doing
it big mistake it's 85 degrees
Jackson's already tired of walking and
so he's melting down why it's melting
down I'm melting down it was a disaster
and we ended up just going home
never again there was one evening this
week that I really stepped out of my
comfort zone so the boys wanted to have
a picnic at the park and play soccer for
dinner today and it's a work night so I
normally wouldn't do this but it's
really nice out it's a beautiful day and
they're having a blast and we're having
a good time are you guys having a good
time yeah if you are a fellow working
parent then you'll understand that at
the end of the day it's just kind of
like food PJ's teeth sleep but I said
yes cuz I had to and it ended up being
one of the most beautiful nights of the
week for us as a family
you know we packed the picnic they
played with their soccer goal that could
best me to play soccer with them and I
said yes because I had to and that's not
something I typically do because I've
never been good at sports and they
didn't care that I was bad and they had
a great time it was really eye-opening
to me to realize that we can spend
weeknights doing quality family stuff
instead of just reserving it all for the
weekends because that's something I
didn't think was possible before the
best day ever
that would you say
[Music]
so she scores on you
so the culmination of this week of
saying yes was really this one thing
that my kids asked me for constantly and
I knew it was coming but I was kind of
dreading it because I didn't know how I
would handle it
this morning I was getting ready for
work yeah
Jackson was like I want to come I
couldn't think of a reason why not are
you guys excited why are you excited to
go to BuzzFeed and I was terrified
because kids are so unpredictable I've
seen my two-year-old being a sweet
perfect angel then I've seen him morph
into a shrinking Banshee in the middle
of the grocery store it ended up being
so much fun but it was really cool first
of all to have everyone I work with meet
both of my kids and I was just really
proud to have these two really well
behaved sweet and polite and respectful
kids at work with me that day it made me
realize that they just really want to
know more about me and what I do and
they want to be around me and it just it
made me feel like maybe I'm not doing
such a terrible job
I think part of it also had to do with
we have this like chocolate covered
raisin funnel that you just like twist
it and they keep coming out and that
might have been the whole reason why
they were happy that day I don't know
I'm just gonna say it's cuz of me so
what did I learn from this whole week I
learned first of all that I say no a lot
of the time out of what I think is
convenience but ends of not being that
much more difficult to say yes and it
ends up being a lot more rewarding I've
learned that there's a better work-life
balance that I can achieve as a parent
it doesn't have to be this like Monday
through Friday is work and Saturday
Sunday is kids and that has been such an
important realization for me because
that's something I struggle with every
day being a working parent and I'm sure
most of you working parents out there
can be late and finally I realize I have
good kids and I know that we all think
our kids are the greatest like obviously
my kids are the greatest but just having
this week to relax and let them make the
choices made me realize how genuinely
great they are
how sweet they are and how smart they
are and I also learned how to make
spaghetti tacos and I also learned that
I am never gonna make those again so
that's all I got for today if you've
tried this experiment or want to try it
or you want me to try anything else in
the future cuz I'm totally on a kick
right now leave it in the comments or
you can text me this is a real number I
do read every single text I don't
necessarily respond because I get a lot
of them but I love to know what you guys
want me to talk about or do in future
episodes until next time I'm gonna try
to take a bite of this spaghetti taco
the one difficulty I'm running into is
keeping this spaghetti in the taco I'm
messy and weird
[Music]